The problem with our code is that user
input gets put into a database query in
an unsafe way.
Some text submitted in the forum
ended up being considered as
SQL code instead of as a text value.
But there's another way to
do our query that's safe.
When we execute a query,
we can put a %s in the query text, and
then after it,
a tuple parameter to the execute call.
The database library will
substitute this into the query in
a way that's safe so
this problem will never happen again.
Using what you've just learned,
you can now update forumdb.py to
execute insert queries safely
using query parameters.
Test your work by checking that
you can now make posts with single
quotes in them and
that the SQL injection attack query
doesn't delete the whole forum anymore.
When you're done, press Submit,
then Continue to go on.